what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for another ghost interview
celebrating a very special thing right
now with Brandon Scott Jones who is a
Critics Choice nominee for best
supporting actor in a comedy series and
then also ghost overall is nominated for
best comedy series so yay that's how it
should be congratulations thank you very
much thank you yeah we're all we were
very very excited it was a very cool
cool thing to happen to the show well
deserved I mean you all know this but
you are one of my favorite comedy series
so this nomination made all the sense in
the world oh my gosh it thank you thank
you very much and it's it's it it's a
really it was a real fun day when we had
that it felt like our first big group
thing which was really really nice so I
like to be a real big cheese ball about
award season because I feel like
sometimes with like prognostication and
doing all the prediction type stuff we
we lose sight of how valuable it can be
both to someone personally getting
nominated but also what it can mean
beyond that as well whether it's to the
show overall or to the industry in
general so what does a nomination like a
CCA nomination mean to you oh my gosh it
it means it means so much first it's
extraordinarily flattering especially
for the show and we were all very
excited because we know that especially
in like this landscape of Television
there's so many opportunities to watch
different things and there's so many
channels there's so many platforms that
there's a lot of competition for
people's eyeballs so to know that people
are watching the show and enjoying the
show I think is the thing that is is you
know is the most meaningful right it's
um it's it's a really really cool
experience to have to share that with
everybody to say that like okay we're up
here in Montreal shooting the show and
it's nice that it goes out into the
world and people are receiving it really
really well it was very moving very
touched I want to make it all about you
now though what what is it mean to you
to you personally does it get I mean I I
would imagine you have confidence in
your craft and we don't do this for
awards but just getting a nomination and
recognition like this kind of means
something to you on a personal level as
well it really does it you know it it
the show that uh that I'm that we're on
is such an ensemble show so it is this
type of thing where I feel
um very luck it reminded me of how lucky
I am to be with those casts because your
performance is only as good as the
people around you and I just feel like
I'm around the best on that show and so
the fact that it happened that that my
name got called that that's very very
very sweet but I know that it could
happen for any of us
um and it's really exciting because you
know as an actor I've always loved the
critics and
I like to hear it that's what we do no
and and no it but it is very very sweet
because you know there's people who you
know are in this profession and they
watch everything and and to and to be
acknowledged in in that regard is really
really wonderful all right now because I
love award season so much and like
getting silly about it I love doing like
end of year lists and this type of stuff
let's say you are in control of your own
award show and you got to make up the
most like wacky out of left field
category and give it to the show the
movie the actor of your choice what
category would you pick and who would
win it oh gosh okay um oh my gosh well I
also will preface this by saying that
for a long time when I was younger
obsessed with award shows like to the
point where one a couple online contests
uh Oscar predictions so this is
something if I was gonna give out the
brandies the Brandy award for me would
be best background actor and it would be
the one that it would be for I wonder
who would I get this year but it's
usually going to be somebody in like um
like a news situation where like there's
a bunch of people like asking questions
at like a press conference and there's
maybe an actor that doesn't have a line
but it's really given a present
performance and so I would go through a
lot of that I would also do that for
triangle of sadness because I feel like
there were so many people on that boat
that were giving extremely Great
Performances and they might not have had
lines so I'm like we got to celebrate
that somehow I love that I I feel like
that should actually be an award
wouldn't it be great it wouldn't it
I mean sit like really uh like honestly
because
even even though we have our main
ensembles and everything nothing will
feel real if the folks in the background
roles are not giving Peak Performance
then you completely ruin the illusion
and it doesn't work 100 a hundred
percent because I think even like
there's those moments where like I'm
like I'm using triangle of sadness just
because it's the movie that stuck with
me a lot this year
um but there's so many times where
they're like rocking back and forth on
that boat or these violent awful gross
things are happening around them and
everybody has to be reacting because if
everyone's not reacting that's not gonna
feel on screen and so I'm like as a
group that cast Main and supporting and
background I felt like did such a great
job I could watch anything and
everything in a horror movie I I get a
little weird about vomit though so I'm
watching like all this gory stuff
throughout 2022 and then I watch
triangle of sadness like looking between
my fingers at the vomit sequence 100 I'm
the same way but with snakes like if I I
could watch literally like skin rip off
somebody I just watched um what was it
Relic the other day did you see that
what a great choice Relic is fantastic
yeah it was really it was like what
incredible performances but then not not
spoiling anything but there's a moment
with some body horror stuff and I was
totally fine watching that but then I
like literally flipped over and like my
TV defaults to like a nature Channel and
there was a snake and I couldn't
couldn't look at it all right I'm glad
I'm in good company you know uh you make
me feel a little bit better about where
I draw the line with these things yes in
the best transition ever from body heart
to to ghosts there we go I wanted to go
back to the beginning so day one when
you were first auditioning for the role
what would you say is the biggest
difference between how you pictured
Isaac then and who he's become now oh my
gosh um that's oh that is such a great
question
um he was in my brain when I first read
him was very very reserved and much
smaller and I think
um as I've gotten a chance to play him
uh he's sort of uh gotten to be a little
bit more flamboyant not necessarily even
in his mannerisms but just in um the way
the way he um interacts with everybody
in the house so I I used to think that I
was like okay let's really lock in as
like the leader in this and that he'll
be just super dry super super grounded
and I think as we've gotten to explore
the character he's gotten to have bigger
pops of emotion I think because I was I
remember the when I got the script and I
got the the the sides for the audition I
remember thinking I was like there's no
way I'm gonna they're gonna buy me as a
as a soldier I just don't have that I
just didn't feel like I had that
gravitas or that that that type of I
don't know just you know you think of
like Stephen Lang and Avatar as like a
soldier you know what I mean and I was
like I don't know if I have that
but as um so I felt like it all had to
be very very rigid and very very
um put together but then as we started
doing a little bit more of it the more
he got to loosen up I feel is and have
more emotion I have think has been like
the most fun and that's to me been like
the differences I guess oh my I can't
imagine the character without those
those kinds of PA really every single
character for that matter it's it's
really incredible how well everybody
plays into their stereotype but also has
those opportunities to take wild
creative swings and have those pops so
literally everyone in this gigantic
Ensemble stands out I'll never get it
we're two seasons in now and I still
can't get over that oh you're very sweet
thank you very much that's that's that's
that's so nice yeah it's it's it was you
know in an ensemble show like that we
were I remember feeling we were all
trying to like figure each other out and
figure out where we all stand and I
remember thinking it was like okay well
the more I keep stuff close to the chest
I think the the better it'll be but then
the fun has been just sort of letting
his steam go and letting his desperation
really peek through you know whereas I
thought in the very beginning he
wouldn't let that stuff come out I had
like the biggest [ __ ] eating grin on my
face because I have a really good
follow-up to that okay we were just
saying at the beginning you were all
trying to figure each other out who was
the easiest to Peg in terms of like
their techniques and what they were
doing and who took you the longest to
figure out in that respect oh that's so
cool um I would say the easiest was
from was Rebecca Rebecca who plays Hedy
um she I feel like came in and just had
this character down pat and like the way
she just moved through the space the way
she held her body it was really really
awesome to watch and I remember watching
her in the pilot episode when we were
filming the pilot and then even in the
first portions of last season seeing
somebody completely
um just like she's going in hard on
Research she knows everything knows that
character front to back in a way that
not that none of us not we're not also
doing that work but in the way that she
kind of put it out there and just like
held the room together with that
character and so I was like okay I see
what you're doing and I'm really really
into it and I thought she was a good
marker for Isaac because she felt like
she had the most status but he was the
character that wanted the most status so
that was the first thing that I remember
sort of like latching onto and then
taking a long time to figure out was
I would say all of the like where the
this is going to be straight but like
almost like the base Nancy and all the
basement ghosts Nancy came in a little
bit later but those basement ghosts have
been around since the very very
beginning and I think figuring out what
their Vibe is against the rest of the
house was really really funny to me I
miss them yes
a couple I was worried that the uh the
inspector that was approving them for
the alcohol license would like go
downstairs and like somehow see
something that they left behind yeah
there has to be some relic of Cholera in
that pit right
you would think so you would think yeah
I know that would be yeah I think that I
know for a fact they are coming back and
there's a few more times so we're gonna
get some cholera ghosts which is great
this is the problem with having such a
big Ensemble and also being so on point
with introducing guest stars with every
single episode is that I just want
everyone to say like this is this is a
lovely wonderful show where I just want
everyone to die so they're always in the
manner together
you know what there's no selfish there's
a selfishness of that too for all of us
ghosts we're like oh there's when we get
a guest star and you're sort of excited
to to see them you realize oh I'm not
gonna be able to talk to them unless
they die maybe they'll die
I will I won't make this one super mean
but it's kind of mean if you if if Isaac
maybe had the opportunity to to kill one
visitor and and keep them as a friend
who do you think he would pick oh my
gosh kill a visitor I think you would
kill Jay because I think he's still in
love with Jay
um but that as a visitor I would say
last season
um there was a couple that was trying to
get married and there was a social media
uh user that uh influencer and I think
deep down Isaac deeply respected that
woman and so I think they would get they
would be they would be good friends I
think that's another thing that I've
wondered with him and that's kind of
that could be the answer there if he had
the opportunity to actually physically
interact with like something modern like
whether it's technology or anything like
what would he choose I I could see him
like getting a phone and being a
Tick-Tock star or something oh 100 I
think he would truly he'd be like really
big on political Tech talk you know what
I'm saying actually this is what we were
talking about when we said the right to
bear arms
um and so he could really add some uh
contextual uh some context for for a lot
of the political discourse that we have
but I also could see him being
absolutely obsessed with Wikipedia and
changing if you could interact with his
own Wikipedia page that thing would be
the longest it would be a novel in and
of itself that actually would be
hilarious I would even just watch an
entire episode of him putting Trevor to
work like word by word changing his
entire Wikipedia yes exactly creating
other websites to support the you know
collaboration going back to the
beginning for you personally as an actor
what what is something that you did in
either season of the show that would
make like day one you auditioning for
Isaac go like wow I never would have
believed that I'd be capable of doing
that in this role one day uh oh
um oh my gosh that's uh capable of doing
that I would say
um
you know there's day one Isaac would be
surprised with
um how uh free the character has become
in terms of the way he even physically
will move through a space I think he's
sort of become a little bit more jaunty
um and which is really fun I think any
time that my character gets to do
something slightly physical I I think I
never could have imagined that I know
that seems almost like benign but there
was something where this character was
very very still the entire time and now
he's sort of like moving around a lot
which would be which is great and
there's also a moment
where this is also very very uh small
but getting to change his hairstyle was
something I never thought I would get a
chance to do and in a couple episodes
I've got to have like a flashback with a
different wig and I thought that was
that was that would blow my mind day one
I've had that a lot with um with hair
makeup and wardrobe it was just crossing
my mind also with the show what we do in
the shadows the idea of like playing a
character who essentially looks the same
in every episode for whatever reason and
then all of a sudden maybe you can
access different corners of them by just
switching up the look yes yeah a hundred
percent that was that was I remember
that was a very exciting time because
you know as an actor when you're doing a
TV show that's not like this you're
going to fittings once a week trying to
get and you know see you know figuring
out your character visually but this is
it this is where you stay and so I think
when we have those little flashback Pops
to get to kind of like go through see
other costumes it really does start to
layer and sort of add background history
to to a performance that you don't get
the chance to access that as much you
know yeah I feel like I can't ask you a
serious question without following it up
with a sillier one but I don't know how
comfortable your costume is but if you
had the opportunity just like you
personally swap with anyone in the show
whose wardrobe would you rather be
wearing flower flower
it looks so comfortable other than the
other than all like the dirt makeup and
so forth the the the actual flowy
costume of it looks so comfortable it's
so I'm like I think about that quite
frequently Rock Solid choice right there
back to the serious stuff looking back
of all of the scenes that you've done
what would you say was the toughest one
for you to crack like you guys get great
scripts on this show but you know
something Isaac goes through or a choice
that he has to make that required you to
sit with that decision more to really
for yourself justify why he did a
certain something
um I I the the first one that comes to
my mind is is when he
kind of comes out of the closet to heady
um in uh last season in season one and I
think the the what what's really
interesting or I guess what I find
challenging and maybe I I shouldn't
maybe I should find some peace with this
is that when a character like this
confesses something and finally releases
something it's not like they've been
holding on to this for like a decade
they've been holding on to this for
centuries and so it feels so much more
enormous and trying to wrap your brain
around like the why now of something and
I agreed like we get this like great
writing and you want to service it but
then there's this like little like actor
inside of you that's sort of like okay
in the 250 plus years that I've been
dead I haven't found the opportunity to
let this come out yet or I've held on to
it for this long and so I remember like
the silliness of that episode of me like
the last ditch attempt of trying to you
know Rebecca and I trying to like or
Rebecca's trying to seduce me and or me
try trying to seduce Rebecca's character
um and then kind of juxtapose that with
like this really like low moment for
this character I thought was that was
hard I remember sitting with that in my
trailer being like don't this up
this kind of pairs well with that and
I'll put a spoiler warning out for our
viewers because at this point I want to
talk a little bit about the uh the
Christmas special and what goes down uh
in that in that double episode but
speaking of like the idea of you know
being able to convey something that he's
been carrying for so long in a half hour
comedy you're you're doing that with
something else here and I'm gonna borrow
words that I heard from you in another
interview you did because I think you
put it really succinctly and accurately
but when when you say that um in those
episodes Isaac is kind of exploring the
idea of like who am I if I'm not the
thing that I said I was that is a really
big thing to tackle in in a half hour
like 20 minute amount of screen time in
an episode so when you knew you were
jumping into stuff like that what became
your top priorities to make sure to you
you were making the most of that idea
but with such little screen time to
actually dig into it
oh Harry this is such a cool question
um that it's and oh my gosh um
I would say the top priority was trying
to find
in that episode specifically or like in
like the Christmas episode hoping that
the performance wouldn't give you
whiplash if that makes sense that
because you could you know obviously
even when you're shooting things out of
order you're going to go ahead and make
a big choice and say okay well this is
the romantic moment where we do finally
kiss or this is the moment where I turn
this person away or this is the moment
where I try to last ditch seduce
somebody or this is the moment where I
finally confess how I who I truly am
and I think that the opportunity of just
saying
um
if
if I can just find if with my scene
partner if we can just find like the
absolute truth of saying like why let's
not lean too hard into the drama of it
let's just lead as hard as we can to
like the truth of what's coming out
right there and I guess the difference
between those two things aren't I you
don't want to go full tiers and then
full comedy because I think it might
feel a little bit jarring but trying to
like temper it to say well you could see
this person in the scene prior about to
burst into tears if they weren't doing
this thing and then hopefully you can
temper it I don't know does that does
that make sense kind of what I'm saying
it does make sense I can apply it to
what we're specifically talking about
and also so many other like deeply human
and important things you guys go through
on this I I feel like I've said this a
number of times when I'm talking but you
have that opportunity to like give the
audience that Whiplash effect and you
never do it you are all able to jump
between real drama and comedy at the
drop of a hat and my my non-acting brain
cannot compute how you actually pull it
off well that honestly that truly that
truly means a lot because I think what
you're you're you you kind of hit the
nail on the head when it's you have 20
minutes and 30 seconds to tell a story
and of that you might be in six minutes
of screen time trying to tell this full
Arc and you just hope that it doesn't go
too hard in One Direction so you try to
find like I guess like the the best way
to answer that is I think we all try to
find the middle ground where at any
moment you could go this way but it's
never so extreme that you're sort of
like freaking out
spot on in that respect I wanted to
bring up Beatrice because I like all
that material quite a bit I would like
to explore that even more so I don't
know if there's anything on the horizon
but let's say there's not is there any
specific you know layer of or corner of
their relationship that you think Isaac
would benefit the most from revisiting
at this point
um I think yeah I I've always felt that
if he were to really take a look back at
his relationship with Beatrice I think
he would realize there's a lot of the
shortcomings and he's already started to
deal with that where he feels like he
wasn't able to give her the life that
maybe she deserved but looking back like
what kind of team were they what type of
they were maybe a little bit more of a
modern romance that we see more publicly
now than we certainly did back then and
see how maybe even though this romance
wasn't
full of you know sacks um and maybe like
deep deep romantic feelings that they
had a love for each other that I think
is just as valuable and I think it would
be really cool for him to try to
understand that there's a difference
between a romantic Mary have a family
love and you know or maybe there's not
as much of a difference and then also
this like this this teamwork where
you're like is it's the same thing if
you're supporting somebody else I would
love to see I guess a good example of
this is I've always imagined them being
able to walk into a dinner party
together and they might have maybe had
the best time and not realized it like
everyone else was a little bit miserable
because they are sort of desperate I
don't know have you seen the movie
cha-cha real smooth I haven't yet that's
so funny like a lot of what you're
explaining is reminding me of that
because that's a that's a movie that
basically takes a look at a modern
relationship and it it twists and turns
the idea of what a soul mate is to
convey that soulmate isn't just meaning
the love of your life and like living
living happily ever after having a
traditional version of a relationship
there's like a million different types
of valuable connections out there to
have yeah yeah I think that's that's
that's almost that's perfect that's a
perfect way to there's a million
different types of connections and for
him I think you know I think what's fun
about ghosts as a whole is that when it
tells a story that's very modern but
dealing with a character from the past I
think that's kind of like a sweet spot
for the show and I think for a character
like Isaac where who just as a
politician is somebody a Founding Father
you know
um you know so rooted in Traditions and
so rooted in all of the idea of of what
specifically in like marriage like oh
this is what the founding fathers wanted
the idea that he was actually doing
something different and doing something
that people are just getting to publicly
explore a little bit more now I think
could be really cool I love exploring
that kind of gray area yeah I have two
not silly questions this one's actually
like a meaningful question you can
answer but it's looking ahead a little
bit let's say Isaac was able to share
more screen time with anyone from the
main Ensemble if you could pick someone
that he would have the most to gain from
at this point in his experience who
would you pick and why oh man
um the most to gain from
I think
I think he could I personally think he
has a lot more to learn from Trevor uh
in the weirdest way because I think he's
I I don't think Isaac really respects
Trevor very much but I think that there
is a hint of
um a confidence that maybe Isaac has
never felt before and I could see
without it turning toxic but I'm sure it
could for comedy's sake but without it
turning too toxic I could see him
learning surprisingly valuable lessons
from from him in terms of he already
started to get it a little bit with the
concept of like fraternity and
friendship and so forth uh but I think
he could find a way to like enjoy life a
little bit more and if Trevor if nothing
else
feels like somebody who has always tried
the hardest to enjoy as much life as
possible maybe that's flower too you
know of like just like loosening up a
little bit because he's so you know this
one's a little sillier and kind of just
for fun considering the possibilities
out there if you had the opportunity to
write a possession body swap episode and
you could have any ghost possess any
living that's been on the show of your
choice which two characters would you
pick oh okay
okay so I I do have this idea of the
ghosts possessing each other but the the
joke for me would always be that Isaac
and Hedy switch bodies and um nobody can
tell
[Laughter]
they're like what no oh yeah sure but um
in terms of like a living I think
I would love
I think it would be
really funny for Mark the contractor to
be
I think for him to get possessed because
he's gets to interact with Jay a little
bit more specifically so I think and as
Jay's pretty much only friend I could
see a fun world where
where Pete getting to possess Pete
getting to possess mark would be really
really fun because I think Pete would
get the chance to hang out with him and
get to actually be the friends that they
want to be I would see that as a really
fun opportunity or best Nancy the caller
goes through this is Sam
I love that too honestly I'd love to see
a rose just like go through the entire
cast just to see her interpretation I
also just love the idea of seeing every
single ghost ultimately possess a living
and having that experience show what's
most meaningful to them whether it's
like to eat as much food as they can or
or maybe to sit down and just like
physically be able to play D and D
something like that wouldn't that be
great yeah I think there is that like
that's one of the fun little gateways at
the show like the there's a couple
little things where you're like okay
there is a chance for them to to
interact with the physical world through
that way so I think yeah to see
everybody get that chance to have Sam
really good go through the Rolodex of it
Sam and Jay both of them like they get
all of it it'll be crazy it's so good
with that material I'm gonna end with a
Renfield question because that trailer
just dropped this morning and my I can't
even say it like blew me away because
that's what I was expecting for a
Dracula film from this team yeah I'll
ask you a Nick Cage specific question
because I was speaking to someone who
had worked with him recently and she was
telling me how he draws from all these
different places and uses uses a like a
wide variety of acting techniques some
of which he doesn't see anybody use
anymore so is there anything that you
saw him do on the set of Renfield that
made even you think like I can't believe
people still do that but it works oh my
god
um yeah well I to kind of like to start
that answer I would say I've one of the
biggest takeaways I had when I came home
from shooting that movie was
you know you think Nicholas Cage has
been in 14
000 movies he's been acting forever he's
one of the best he's so so good and you
know there's this maybe cynical side of
yourself that you don't even know exists
and I'm gonna say yourself I'm kind of
talking about myself where you're like
uh kind of assume that maybe they're
just sort of like going on autopilot or
whatever and I watched this man come
into work sit in the makeup trailer
get all made up as Dracula and then show
up on set and was so excited and so I'm
oh my God I almost got a little
emotional because it was really moving
to see someone love the craft so much
and he had these really funny moments
where he um I remember him being like
here wait wait uh I just want to try
something really quick and then he would
just like make a facial expression into
the camera just so they could have it
like he know like he was he's always he
he just felt like he was always
exploring this character every chance he
got to be on screen
um and the little bit of screen time
that we get to share together it was
really cool one I'll tell you the one of
the coolest things was uh there's a
moment where we're I can't oh I can't
really say anything about spoilers but
like
um he
it was he pitched me a line he was like
whoa wait wait I got an idea I got an
idea say this and that was my Nicholas
Cage that's pretty good oh thanks yeah
um but he was like oh wait wait he's
like let's do it again and then he was
like say this he like pitched me a line
a joke to say and it was really really
cool just to see him just so in it and
fun and having the time of his life uh I
don't know me I can't say it was a time
of his life but I can tell you that it
looked like it was he was having a blast
and it was a blast to be around it too
none of this surprises me I feel like
I've always gotten this impression from
him but you know I I guess for obvious
reasons it was unbearable weight of
massive talent that like it was shining
a bigger Spotlight on that quality of
his craft than ever and it just became
abundantly clear that he is that type of
actor and I love that it's it's so it's
so cool and then now he's playing
Dracula in a universal movie he's like
part of the Dracula Canon now and it's
like how lucky are we to be alive during
this period of time
so excited excited for that I am so
excited for more ghosts I might have had
a sneak peek at some upcoming episodes
and yet again they're excellent Brandon
thank you so much for talking to me
today and huge huge huge congratulations
on both CCA nominations I am always
rooting for you and the team oh my gosh
thank you Perry this is as always the
best talking to you